[Musique]
l'action voix de quartier a été lancée
ce mardi 8 décembre à saint pierre au
foyer albert barbeau de la fondation
père favron une action menée dans le
cadre du plan de transition écologique
et solidaire lancée par la collectivité
qui prévoit la plantation d'un million
d'arbres sur le territoire l'engagement
que nous prenons nous c'est
effectivement de mettre à disposition
des surfaces
pour que ces sommes soient plantés mais
c'est ensuite de les entretenir
alors s'est entretenue par le personnel
par les résidents eux-mêmes qui
participent ceux qui le peuvent
parce que tous ne seront pas en capacité
bien évidemment de s'en occuper mais le
fait d'arroser des plantes tous les
jours ou tous les deux jours
c'est une activité que nous leur offrons
en supplément sans compter le bien-être
qui se dégage de pouvoir se promener
dans un endroit où des élèves du collège
saint charles sont venus participer à
cette plantation des jeunes très
investis qui ont compris l'importance de
cette action
un cheveu trouvé ça trop vos
connaissances tu fais que pas
aujourd'hui donc je trouvais ça hyper
important du mercantour
les arbres des milk alors certes un
million ce n'est pas assez mais je pense
que c'est un bon commencement déjà les
arbres ça fit le co2 donc ça des
polluent l'air et que ça laisse un
patrimoine pour les générations futures
un million d'arbres une action qui a
démarré en août 2019 qui vise à planter
un million d'individus d'espèces
indigènes et endémiques de la réunion
sur cinq ans il ya un volet préservation
de la biodiversité restauration des
milieux naturels donc là c'est ce que le
département a l'habitude de faire en
milieu naturel on reconstitue enfin on
restaure des forêts dégradées
il ya un autre volet qui est plus lié au
développement économique parce que l'on
sait que autour de la biodiversité
il peut y avoir justement de la création
d'emplois et le dernier volet c'est ce
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui sur le
secteur de bois d'olive c'est un volet
qui a son petit nom aux boîtes quartier
est en fait là c'est comment on ramène
de la biodiversité dans dans les
quartiers comme on inverse justement la
tendance à la perte de biodiversité en
disant vas l'urbanisation à grignoter
sur les milieux naturels maintenant on
va inverser cette tendance et on va
ramener les milieux naturels dans les
quartiers dans les zones urbaines
ces plantations se feront sur l'ensemble
du territoire de la réunion comme ici à
bois d'olives près du pont du bras de la
plaine ou encore à saint pol le long de
la route départementale
[Musique]